Since our concern in this course is with operating systems, I'm going to
leave you to explore most of the physical layer on your own,
and focus on the part that has implications for the operating system
at the edge of the network, and end users like you and
me. The most important piece of hardware for us, then, is the
network interface card, or NIC. This typically is a direct memory access,
or DMA device. Meaning that once connected to the memory bus, it
has the ability to read and write from memory, on its own,
independent of the CPU. Typically, the CPU specifies through the
bus, the range of memory it wants to be sent, whether
it's a read of write, and then sets the go
bit, to let the NIC begin. The NIC then tries to
copy the data, as requested. Because the NIC controller puts
all of the copy instructions on the bus, the CPU doesn't
have to. He can go about his business, to the extent
that he finds the information he needs in the CPU cache,
there won't be any contention on the memory
bus. Only when the NIC finishes either sending
or receiving a packet, need he bother the
CPU with an interrupt. The NIC controller is
also responsible for putting hardware specific headers and
footers on the data. For physical ethernet, this
would include an inter-frame gap of silence, and
a special preamble, to indicate the startup of frame.